[Music]
this is much much worse than Ebola Ebola
requires very close contact for
transmission people are very scared of
him they were guilty of asking Harvey
Weinstein to do things making him
believe that they wanted to be with him
we should not go in and trash an area of
the globe about which we know hardly
anything Marie Curie was extraordinary
so in truth she won two Nobel prizes and
I think it's sort of in a way from to
keep the great forces you win won and
you're not satisfied so you win it in
physics you retrain in chemistry and you
win it again the global threat from
kovat 19 was made clear today by the
scientists who helped discover Ebola
professor Peter Piot the leading expert
in his field told Sky News that
coronavirus poses a greater threat
because it's so infectious
he also criticized Donald Trump's
approach to the developing crisis our
science correspondent Thomas Miller
reports on the professor's expert
warning this is much much worse than
Ebola Ebola requires very close contact
for transmission people are very scared
of it but frankly it is usually very
contained I mean we have some exceptions
but it's because it's a respiratory
transmitted virus that makes it so
worrisome and it's very infectious
because there's so much virus in the
throat so this is literally something
you can catch by just talking to
somebody
he said president Trump's restriction on
non-us citizens flying from many
European countries makes little sense
the virus is already widespread and
largely undetected in the United States
thank you once again President Trump
took everybody by surprise by a decision
which is frankly pretty bizarre in the
sense the US has in country transmission
as lots of cases so I can only think
that this is a political decision and
it's hard to imagine that
would have any impact on control of
ghovat 19 there will be many thousands
of cases and more deaths in the coming
weeks but so far modern medicine has
little to help those most vulnerable
because there is no treatment there is
no vaccine we're relying on on good
hygiene is almost back to the dark ages
of Medicine in many ways and it's this
basic principles here it's like back to
the times of the Spanish flu 100 years
ago where that killed you know 50
million people however we have
antibiotics that can treat pneumonia
there are respirators we we are better
equipped and I'm quite optimistic that
ok let's say by April sometime in April
we will have effective therapy there's
reasonable hope that we will know soon
vaccine that's going to take a much
longer time Boris Johnson described the
outbreak as the worst public health
crisis in a generation
so is he ok doing enough to combat it
while much of mainland Europe is taking
much more drastic measures including the
closure of schools the Prime Minister is
facing criticism but from both
scientists and from the former
conservative Health Secretary Jeremy
Hunt for not taking tough enough action
to contain the viruses spread but the
UK's chief scientific adviser Sir
Patrick valence of sold Sky News the
government is taking the right action
for now the UK says you done a good job
of contact tracing and isolating so the
first phase of this means that we've a
little bit behind we in terms of where
the outbreak is compared to others and
the measures that were announced which
is about self isolation even if you've
got very mild symptoms will mean a large
number of people actually at home being
isolated because of this infection
that's a very big measure actually it's
going to have quite a big impact across
a number of households a number of
people so I don't think that's a trivial
measure it's all in all the modelling
suggests that these sorts of measures
the ones that have the biggest impact it
is the case of course that if you
completely locked down absolutely
everything probably for a period of 4
months or more
then you would suppress this virus all
of the evidence from previous epidemics
suggests that when you do that and then
you release it it all comes back again
so the other part of this is to make
sure that we don't end up with a sudden
peak again in the winter which is even
larger which causes even more problems
we do face the prospect of an increasing
number of people dying
that is a real prospect this is a nasty
disease for most people it's a mild
disease it's important to know we don't
know yet nobody knows what proportion of
people have this who are completely
asymptomatic so the only cases that
we've really got at the moment are
people who've had symptoms or largely
people who've had symptoms that means
that even estimating exactly what the
death rate is from this is quite
difficult dollar a to know is
unflinching in her loyalty towards
Harvey Weinstein known as a legal
Rottweiler she has a formidable record
defending men in sex assault cases you
were accused during the trial of
taunting witnesses of bringing them to
tears of inducing panic attacks how do
you reflect on that now you know the
people that criticized me I don't think
they really think about the big picture
and I don't understand what they were
hoping for were they hoping that we
would let people walk into a courtroom
tell their stories and not be asked any
questions it doesn't make any sense
that's not how a court procedure works
Weinstein's conviction is seen as a
landmark moment in the me2 movement the
trial obviously had little forensic
evidence and zero forensic evidence so
it was down to the testimony of these
women and ultimately that was accepted
by the jewelry do you accept that things
are changing in the way these kinds of
cases are tried if this becomes a
pattern or a model for the way juries
decide cases I think every single person
who finds themselves charged with a
crime should be concerned because if we
are finding people guilty where there
are mountains of doubt and very little
evidence
if any at all I think we need to
question what the justice system looks
like when you have sexual assault cases
the idea of a woman coming to police
with a test tube of evidence
it just isn't realistic as it is to be
here and true it's not a believable
ending no but the question is do you
have to believe someone just because
they make a statement if you're looking
at it from a more moral lens everyone's
guilty but that's not what we do in a
criminal justice system that's not how
it works these women look guilty they
were guilty of a lot of things they were
guilty of using Harvey Weinstein they
were guilty of asking Harvey Weinstein
to do things making him believe that
they wanted to be with him that they
wanted to spend time with him and then
get up on a witness stand and call him
disgusting sending him letter saying
miss you big guy did that behavior
Warren sexual assault we're talking
about two different things you're asking
me if the women were guilty I'm telling
you that they were guilty of certain
things no behavior warrants sexual
assault you have said that you have
never been sexually assaulted because
you've never put yourself in that
situation so are you implying that there
is choice in being sexually assaulted I
am implying that there is choice in the
circumstances in which we put ourselves
you see the accepting of a world where
there are sexual predators and it's up
to win it no I'm a realist I change
they're nice to cannibal I'm not at all
I'm accepting of a world that bad things
happen in it's unrealistic to think that
it doesn't what about the man's role in
this I don't think men have any power
anymore how does a man have power today
if a woman can say anything she wants
and they're gonna be believed that takes
away every ounce of power that a man has
the pendulum is swinging so far in
another direction that I think it's
dangerous and scary and nobody's gonna
change my mind about that
[Music]
Sir David Attenborough says governments
must enforce a ban on industrial mining
of the deep-sea because he fares big
business could trash the oceans Sir
David who is speaking exclusively to Sky
News back to new report by fauna and
flora international that says the thirst
for heavy metals like cobalt could lead
to widespread and destructive mining the
world has become very anxious to get
hold of rare metals which till now have
been found in crisis in Africa
particularly which we use in many of the
modern electronic apparatus particularly
batteries and so there has been a big
search put on and human beings being the
sort of people there are they they look
everywhere and someone says what about
the deep seas and stuff there and the
certain indications that there could be
what we are asking is that we should not
go in and trash an area of the of the
globe about which we know hardly
anything until we've done the proper
research on this issue at the moment of
of coronavirus now I know you've talked
in in the past talk actually quite
recently about overpopulation the amount
of people on the planets and the affect
that is in particular having or on other
species could this be another dimension
of that of people living cheek-by-jowl
and then the ability of viruses tick to
pass through quite easily like death
when was that 14th century something no
not so many people around the Black
Death killed thousands of people
thousands of people and the besides the
world population or indeed the
population of this country or Europe was
tiny compared with what it is now so if
epidemics can go around the world and
have gone round the world in the past I
would like to say whoa whoa it's all our
fault because that's the kind of
fashionable thing to say that we were
overpopulated now but it just doesn't
but that argument doesn't hold water in
your hopes for cop 26 in Glasgow of
course in the United Kingdom the global
focus on our role in this country on
advancing the the battle against climate
change
do you have high hopes for that or is it
could it just turned out to be a nice
hulking shot
I have desperate hopes for that what cop
coming up in Glasgow is going to have to
say is how where is the money
who's going to do with it it's going to
deal with nuts and bolts with practical
politics we know where we've got to go
we know what the dangers are we know how
to fix them but now we've got to do it
you know you sound an awful lot like
grater tunberg there and your
generations with greatest respect
generations apart but I mean is it her
and her generation people like her who
were going to hold feet to the fire to
make sure this follow-through from
things like cop 26 my my reading of
graduates on burgers that she is very
respectful for the science and she says
in a modest way I'm not a scientist I
have not studied the the upper
atmosphere of the past thirty years but
I know people who have and I know what
they say and the rest of the world ought
to take notice that's all she's asking
and that's I think how you've always
conducted your career is it nicety yes
well I I mean I'm ignorant of the
science of the upper atmosphere
I'm don't pretend to be I meant might
know rather more about chimpanzees and
penguins
[Music]
now back in December 2018 British
backpacker grace Mullane was murdered by
a man she had met for a date in New
Zealand speaking after her killer was
convicted Grace's father said her
family's lives had been ripped apart in
our project that started as a small way
to honor her memory and challo their
grief has gone worldwide
well inspired by greatest love of
handbags the family started collecting
them and then what they did was they
filled them with essential items and
donated them to their local Women's
Refuge centres and domestic abuse
charity in Essex
well now the love grace campaign has
gone international receiving and
distributing handbags around the world
and I'm delighted to say that I'm joined
by Gracie's cousin Hannah a Callaghan in
the studio Hannah good afternoon to you
hello what a wonderful way to honour
grace talk to me about how this started
because it must have been well such a
heart-wrenching and difficult time for
your family so to find a positive way to
channel your energy and focus your minds
how did it lead you to this when grace
was murdered in New Zealand the White
Ribbon charity worked with local people
and the New Zealanders to hold vigils
and to raise awareness and then we
decided in the UK we wanted to do
something similar so we've been working
with the white ribbon charity we've been
fundraising for them and what they do is
they raise awareness of domestic abuse
violence mail violence against women and
we thought you know that's a good that's
what we can use our platform to raise
awareness for now we're looking at 6,500
bags that have been donated and
distributed worldwide not just in the UK
so we've had New Zealand USA Canada all
wanting to run appeals on our behalf and
we're about to set one up in Australia
as well which is fantastic this is what
I love about the message on the card
telling the woman who receives this
vital bit of kit that will mean so much
them at the lowest point in their life
is that it tells them about grace
because often when you speak to women
who have been a victim of domestic abuse
or charities who help women of domestic
abuse is that we
so easily become statistics when it
comes to this but it's important to
remember the stories of those women
because they are women they are people
they are not just victims they are not
just numbers is that what you tried to
do here by reminding people of who grace
was before she made the headlines yes
everybody knows Grace's story but we
wanted to tell them about grace you know
she was fun-loving family orientated and
just wanted to travel so we wanted to
tell them a little bit about her because
she could have been anybody's sister
cousin daughter so I think it resonates
a lot with people because they can see
themselves in grace when they read that
message and Hanna how has this helped
you and your family because obviously
this happened to grace in New Zealand
not all of your family could go over
there and fight the fight for grace and
grieve over there and go through that
many of you will have had to watch it
unfold from the UK has this been a good
way of coping yeah it's a practical
thing for us to do we wanted to use our
platform to raise awareness it's
incredibly cathartic for us to be able
to go through the bags and pack them and
to then deliver them to these centres
and it's not going to bring her back but
if we can use what happened to her to
stop it happening to others then that's
all we can do
[Music]
now my next guests got more than she
bargained for when she took a break to
California to escape her busy city life
in London fair Nelson is here to tell us
more about her trip to the Joshua Tree
Park in California hi what happened I
was hiking in Joshua Tree
I'd been hiking there for a couple of
weeks and I was doing a long day hike
when I was trying to cross some boulders
and I fell 25 feet I shattered my pelvis
so I couldn't walk and I couldn't sit up
and I realized I didn't have any phone
signal and I didn't hadn't told anybody
where I was going they always out there
for four days in three nights four days
yeah it's cold in the desert it's cold
in visit at night and it's very very hot
during the day so it was about trying to
keep myself both my spirits are spirits
up and keep myself alive to take care do
you have enough water I ran out of water
on the second day and so then I had to
start drinking urine talk to me about
what was going through your mind how you
managed to convince yourself that you
weren't going to die there and that you
were going to get hurt I wasn't always
necessarily convinced that I was not
going to die but I try to put that out
of my brain and just focus on if I stay
alive long enough that somebody will
know and notice that I'm missing that's
the only way I'm going to get out of
here so it was about trying to focus on
what can I do to keep myself going
rather than thinking too much about the
reality of the situation I was in so
what did you do I made a sunsha sunshade
out of my hiking stick with a plastic
bag and I had to help it up over myself
for like the four thousands hours hours
and I used the same stick to apply
sunscreen to my legs to stop myself from
burning so you were wearing shorts I was
wearing shorts EAN a singlet top and how
did you finally manage to get out so
friends notice that I was quiet on
social media which was really the main
way that people kept track of what I was
doing in my travels and so they
eventually the friends I was
house-sitting for asks their friends to
come and check on the house and find out
where I was I wasn't there they
contacted search and rescue who found my
car at
trailheads and realized that I'd been
out there for some time
okay and they came to get you talk to me
about that moment when they arrived yeah
I was day four I was not in a very good
way and I heard a helicopter going over
I couldn't see it but I could hear it
and then I heard them say we're looking
for a hiker and I had to wave my stick
as as much as I could to get their
attention and it took them coming over
two more times before I heard them say
the words we see you and we're going to
come and get you and I will never forget
those words they're in my brain for
forever how long did it take you to
recover
I took been nine months to I was back on
my feet and able to go hiking again so
they had to rebuild sure they had to put
pins in my pelvis and then I had three
months where I was in a wheelchair and
then I had to slowly learn to build
strength up to walk again okay and
mentally mentally it's it just it's just
changed the way I look at everything now
this is no point being afraid of things
and everything feels like a bonus now
[Music]
I've discovered a new element you
changed the world Marie Curie was
extraordinary
through and through she she won two
Nobel prizes and I think it's sort of in
a way from the great forces you win one
and you're not satisfied so you win it
in physics you retrain in chemistry and
you win it again I think that's pretty
pretty cool but there it has so much
relevance and importance her win because
you know originally she was not on the
nomination it was only Becker Elle and
her husband Pierre Curie who was on the
nomination and her husband stood up for
as very few men would have at that time
in the early nineteen hundreds even
today and said you know if there's a
nobel prize to be won then we're both
going to be on that nomination and and
he had it changed you know because
really the the the pursuit of
radioactivity they did discover it
together but it was her notion that led
them into their you know hours and hours
of study and careful manual labor and
careful scientific brain work and and
that it was it was her notion that let
the whole thing around the movie dwells
on the difference between Mary the
scientist and Mary the mother do you
think that's central to understanding
her character and also the way that
society treats treats women differently
as mothers she has a very scientific way
of loving her kids but they gain you
know you cannot be a magnificent
scientist a perfect spouse a perfect
mother you know today has only 24 hours
like even Superman Kamath make all of
that in one clearly the films about the
world of science but the film industry
has recently been rocked by the me to
movement do you think that's a watershed
moment for the industry and for society
and do you think that's what we need to
finally shift the narrative well I'm
actually interested in women who speak
the truth to power and I think if
anything comes out of the mute to
movement it's that it's that girls are
going to have the courage to do that in
our industry you know I'm certainly the
young girl that I'm working with now on
the series I'm shooting I'm encouraging
too
to do that at every turn you know
something's not right speak up about it
don't say you know I've got to do this
sex scene on Monday and nobody's
discussed it with me make sure someone
discusses it with you or don't show up
you know make sure you have that
conversation make sure you're protected
you know speak your truth to power and
Mary Colvin did that she voiced she gave
a voice to the to the voiceless she
found the most vulnerable people on
earth and and and told the truth about
their suffering and Marie Curie spoke
the truth to power at every turn she
went before the French government and
said this is what we you know your your
your system is shoddy men are being you
know men are dying on your battlefields
unnecessarily they're being amputated
without you cause let me have my mobile
x-ray units and I will show you a
different way to do things you know so I
think the things I'm drawn to a courage
and speaking one's truth it is not a job
I want but it is a job I will take
[Music]